en Chile la discusión política luego del
plebiscito en que se rechazó la
propuesta de una nueva constitución en
nuestro país se trasladó al congreso es
allí en donde se está desarrollando el
proceso para poder tener una nueva Carta
Magna pero en las últimas semanas el
ambiente político aquí en el país se ha
visto bastante enrarecido por una serie
de situaciones que han marcado y que han
generado un nuevo escenario si esto se
ha planteado bajo el rótulo de aprietes
que no es más que amedrentamiento
político se generaba una situación
bastante particular con un exe barrista
un exe barra brava alias panchomalo
Francisco Muñoz quienes están dentro de
un denominado Team patriota y se han
dedicado las últimas semanas a emplazar
a distintos parlamentarios que están
participando del proceso Constituyente
en el congreso en Chile esto ha generado
gran discusión también preocupación de
parte de las autoridades y de los mismos
parlamentarios que se han visto
afectados por esta situación se está
discutiendo en el último tiempo de donde
proviene el financiamiento de Estas
actividades específicamente pero hasta
ahora no se ha podido determinar es sin
duda un tema que preocupa y ocupa las
autoridades y que está marcando también
el derrotero luego del proceso
Constituyente aquí en Chile